[Music]
>> Hi there.
This is Manish Malik.
I'm an applied scientist at
Relevance and AI team.
That's my colleague Doran and
Nilesh.
And we all work on InfoBots,
which is conversational Q and A
powered by AI.
And as part of that, we're
building some amazing AI
capabilities like understanding
the conversational questions,
doing reading comprehension to
extract the answers, do
inference on a piece of text to
infer the answers, and then do
machine writing to convert the
answer in a more natural
language way.
You'll see -- we'll show you
some of the demo today, but you
see in the middle some of our
best-in-class reading
comprehension models.
And on the right is the demo
that I'm going to show you just
now.
So if you look at this, this is
a user session where a user asks
who is the father of modern
physics, and we show the answer
right here, but now we're
introducing this chat button
which is really going to do
conversational search
experience.
So think of this as Bing
becoming more conversational now
because we can understand and
have conversations.
We can answer any question from
the Internet, whether it's from
a specific website or a generic
question.
So when you click the chat
button, this window opens and
now you can ask questions.
So you'll see that we understood
the context was who is the
father of modern physics, and
now the next question is what
about chemistry.
We were able to understand that
the user was asking who is the
father of modern chemistry.
And we were able to not just
answer the question but also
extract the answer and show it
at the top.
And with the goal of really
helping the user quickly find
the information that they're
looking for and understanding
their conversational type of
questions.
The next question is:  Did
Einstein win Nobel Prize?
We were able to answer that
question.
When did he win?
And if you hover over this,
Nilesh, it's going to show that
the answer was right there,
1922.
And we were able to extract the
answer and show it at the top.
And then we are also able to
understand when the question is
a conversational question or a
chitchat question or an
info-seeking question.
So if you say, are you real,
we're able to do very limited
chitchat, where were you born,
and we're able to also
understand the switch between
when the conversational -- when
the question becomes chitchat
question or an info-seeking
question.
So if the next question is a
garter snake venomous, we're
able to answer that question.
And if you look at the next
question, what about king cobra,
and now we're not just answering
the question, we're doing
inference on top of it to say
that yes, king cobra is indeed
venomous.
If you show a little bit up, go
a little bit up, Nilesh.
The reason why -- this is a very
interesting example:  Is garter
snake venomous?
The reason why we didn't do
inference here is because it's
very, very hard, when you look
at this text, even for humans,
to make a conclusion or
inference that garter snake is
venomous or not, because it says
garter snakes were long thought
to be nonvenomous but they have
a gland that does produce a
venom.
So it's very hard.
So our model is not super
confident whether we can infer
the information or not.
Just to wrap up, I guess what
this demo is really showing is
that we're building some great
AI technology and working on
some amazing research problems
and hoping to really make Bing
more conversational and really
advance the advent of AI
technology.
My name is Manish Malik.
So you're welcome to reach out
to us.
You can go to -- we're currently
experimenting on Bing.com.
So you'll start to see these
chat windows open up in your
experiments when you go to
Bing.com, but we haven't shipped
yet to all the users.
So keep an eye out for InfoBots.